[موسيقى
] بالإيطالية نقول buonano
لدينا تقاليد قديمة جدًا في
إطلاق ملابسنا القديمة والتخلص منها بعيدًا عن
النافذة ، وهذا يعني
الاقتراب من أذن جديدة
بأفكار أه
ثاقبة وسعيدة بشأن
المستقبل وبالطبع هذا يعني التخلي
عن القديم  أسوأ ماضٍ
في اليابان نقول أكيماستي
في العام الجديد راهب
يقرع الجرس الكبير
لننسى
أفكارنا في العام
الماضي حلقة تدق الأجراس مائة وثمان مرات
في ألمانيا نقول ضوضاء الصقيع وما
نفعله كل عام هو نذوب الرصاص
ورميها في الماء البارد
وشكل هذا الصمام يخبرنا عن
ثروات العام المقبل نقول
سنة جديدة سعيدة في
feliz ange nuevo الإسبانية ،
عادة ما نأكل 12 حبة
عنب وعندما نستمع إلى الأجراس
نأكل العنب في نفس الوقت  لذلك لا يمكننا
فك دوس تريس كواترو حتى سن الثانية عشر.
نحن
دائمًا نرتدي شيئًا أحمر
يبدو وكأنه تقليد ولكن
الأهم هو 12 حالة اغتصاب
في هولندا
نقول إننا
ما نفعله تقليديًا في أول يوم  في
يناير ، نقوم بغوص العام الجديد
حيث يقفز الكثير من الهولنديين
إلى الماء المثلج للاحتفال بالعام الجديد ،
مرحبًا من سنغافورة ،
نتحدث أربع لغات
الإنجليزية الماليزية الماندرين
والتاميل ، لذا قلنا بلغة الماندرين غناء نيان
كوايل وفي الملايو نحن  say salamat tahun
baru
[موسيقى]